there's there's one really great example
that's popping in the news and it's this
Dylan Mulvaney I think the individual's
name is uh it's some of the funniest
content I mean Dylan Dylan says that
they're a performer putting on a
performance and I respect that and think
the performance is very very funny the
only thing is
it's at the expense of women right Dylan
Mulvaney throws out a familiar posted
his video got invited to the White House
and got a cookie and the whole
performance and again I'll stress this
Mulvaney says outright that this is a
performance I bring that up and people
are like no it's serious no it's serious
and I'm like I mean maybe Dylan's
literally trans but the character
they're playing is exaggerated over the
top performance and it's you know when
they say Woman face I'm like no that
that's literally what this is right it's
it's you the point I'm trying to make is
you mentioned that even trans people are
getting concerned about what's going on
Blair white being a good example because
Dylan Mulvaney's character is a
caricature of women and trans people not
indicative of who trans people really
are so you have this person who's trip
it went high heels while going hiking
and and just this very cartoonish
character and it's got It's got a lot of
trans people and women angry that
they're being mocked by this performance
well conservatism is not confined to one
ideology right there are there are
conservative Democrats right they're
conservative gay people right so you
know conservatism can Encompass a wider
branch of philosophies than most people
might might think it's not concern it's
not confined to republicanism but hey uh
you know Biden really likes Dylan
Mulvaney and according to Dylan who came
out today he says that Biden said that
he watches his Tick Tock Channel and
that they're going to going to come out
with an official conversation and
interview this coming Sunday so that's
going to be very interesting to watch
but but to the point that you guys are
making here I think it's important to
note here that you know a lot of the
times when people are a part of
different communities especially in the
conservative kind of wing they usually
don't make it their personality
sometimes they do and it's a little bit
annoying but when you just come to the
table and say hey my sex my gender my
choice of how I decide to procreate is
everything all about me it's kind of
annoying and it kind of takes away from
the human being and that's what you see
from a lot when it comes to a lot of
these social media personalities that
just use it as a way to have a fake
personality I think it's possible to get
to the point well I see one of two
features one where offensive comedy
comes back with it with a Vengeance and
you start seeing like remember when
Sarah said priors and stuff yeah yeah I
mean when George Carlin George Carlin
called Richard Pryor and Eddie Murphy
the n-word on stage to thunder supplies
like I mean it's it's shocking it's true
but it's true yeah he did outright and
the point he was making is that it was a
joke because you know they're not like
it was meant to be absurd you know that
George Carlin is a hippie who doesn't
really believe in the stuff and he was
mad it was meant to be shocking and
offensive but you can't do that kind of
stuff these days maybe it'll go swing in
the complete other direction or maybe
it will come to the point where Woman
face becomes extremely offensive and
people like Dylan Mulvaney get banned
for a for
um misogyny but how do you do that I
mean like do you how do you rally women
around that to like to reclaim Womanhood
that doesn't that it isn't some entirely
conservative female movement I mean are
liberal females really going to get on
board with a reclaiming you know Woman
face like so I mean you've gotta well my
point is maybe I'm not saying right now
I mean I don't know where we're at I
just I wonder what the psychology is
there have to be some kind of polarizing
event I I what I what I see is either
the woman face phenomenon results in
people saying mockery of any identity is
is fair play or it turns into you know
what we've realized for some time that's
probably not okay to mock women in this
way but shouldn't it be okay though
shouldn't it be shouldn't it shouldn't
everybody be up for grabs like when you
were kids there was always that one
serious kid who told the teacher every
time somebody said something mean about
him and then the rest of us were all
having a laugh or having a joke right I
mean I don't think it should be illegal
or banned or anything like that but
people are allowed to have tastes you
know what I mean like like Sarah
Silverman did blackface personally I'm
not a fan of it George Carl I'm a huge
fan of but his joke where he calls Eddie
Murphy and Richard probably the n-word
that's I'm not I'm not all about that
you know I understand his point about
being offensive I think he should be
allowed to do it I think he can make his
joke and turns out tons of people really
loved what he said good for him I you
know that's not my thing are you
exciting place for blackface you know
what I mean is it like is there you know
let's say you're doing a documentary or
a film about Al Jolson right so I mean
like there is a time and place to do
blackface right so I mean the only thing
that we're calling out Sarah Silverman
for is the hypocrisy of the left right
right because she did blackface but you
mean doing blackface in so far as you're
mocking what it what it represented yes
like the the joke of modern blackface
with someone like Sarah Silverman was
that
you're you're sort of making fun of the
old ways when when these people were
racist and it was wrong and you're
supposed to be shocked by it and it's
funny because it's deeply offensive you
know what I mean like wasn't that what
Al Jolson was doing though originally
like he was doing a parody of the black
face not only that but like RDJ like
Robert Downey Jr and that would be
Tropic Thunder right right right
specifically this it's exactly what
we're talking about to poke fun at the
people who do it yes right I think the
traffic Thunder is hilarious it is and
the gag was actors who go too far into
method acting and it went so far he
actually did blackface he well it's more
than that like his character got like
skin pigmentation like it's a while I I
just say personally myself let people
say and do and express themselves as
they want as long as they don't
physically hurt other people people
should be able to control their own
emotions we shouldn't be policing
conversation speech and art let it
express itself and if someone wants to
be distasteful that is their uh
perspective and opinion but it's also
your opinion to get triggered and angry
and emotional about it so at the end of
the day people's words and actions only
have power if you give them that power
and I think if a lot of more of us were
more mature about this we we could have
a situation where we didn't have
censorship we didn't have of course the
destruction of free speech and the
progression of society but sadly we we
do because people saying I don't like
this this is offending me stop him right
now and I think that's just weak and I
think that's that's that's well as with
a low vibrational energy that's not good
for human consciousness well as of a lot
of things right like the woke people
will take like a grain of Truth and then
spin it around it a yarn of Lies so
emotional abuse is a real thing right a
use of institutional power to
emotionally abuse an affected group
that's a real thing the problem is is
that when you take when you take that
and then you liberalize it and you
expand it into you know an entire web
then you go too far and then there's
going to be collateral damage so the
question is how do you define what is
emotional abuse that's the problem right
and that's the the realm of therapists
to be able to answer a question like
that maybe you guys know more than I do
but at some point you know I hate
bullies right I can't stand bullies you
know when you see somebody being bullied
because of their race or their sexuality
or something like that you want to stand
up against that right at least I do
right that for me I'm not a conservative
I'm a Libertarian so how do you do that
right without saying oh you're you're
just a woke social justice where you're
taking the side of the left or something
like that how do you stand up for the
rights of affected minorities from
actual emotional abuse without crossing
over into something larger effective I
just want to say confront the bully
directly to their friends Dave Chappelle
I think said it best you don't like it
don't watch it if you don't like what I
say you don't have to listen to it if
you choose to watch and listen certain
things and if you don't like someone you
don't like their taste that you you got
offended by them don't watch them it's
your choice at the end of the day
remember that Viral tweet that I think
it was Tyler the Creator and he said how
is cyber bullying a real thing like Just
Close Your Eyes just like turn the
screen off kind of work but here's the
thing we're guys we're all guys we don't
have any women at this table those young
girls bully the the absolute hell out of
each other and these when they're on
their social media with the things that
they're saying the bullying in high
school it's not like when we were
growing up guys it's different but in
the pictures they've got nudes of each
other they they reach you at home
they're you know it's an insane level of
harassment yeah so this is actually it's
a good point because for these kids it
used to be that if you went to school
and you had problems when you went home
you were safe from what that stressor
was but the next day you had to go face
it today with social media and online
personas it's it's Infinity it's never
going anywhere and so we're seeing
suicide we're seeing depression mostly
among young girls so yeah I mean I think
I think really it's going to come down
to the parents to be like no cell phone
for you is the depression because of
bullying or is it because of the
algorithms that perfectly highlight and
curate and and upvote particular context
that causes drama that causes anger that
gets people's attention and they know if
they say something negative they'll get
people responding to it if they post
something degenerate they're they'll get
more eyeball and the algorithm will
reward them for this and I think I think
there's an argument to be made here
because you know I grew up in in New
York City I grew up in Brooklyn there
there was bullying on insane levels
there was there was a kid who who you
know one day wasn't coming in for a few
months he was burnt all throughout his
body he lost his father in a fire there
was a bully calling him sausage face
punching him beating him up
psychological abuse where you couldn't
escape it there was gangs there was
people bullying each other to the extent
where you couldn't even go outside in
many instances because you would get you
know kicked in stomped on I got stomped
on a couple times I got I got bullied
like crazy because I didn't even okay so
so I'm saying there always was bullying
yes but but who are you gonna you know
point the finger at to well so the
algorithm or the individual it's both
it's both but I just want to point out
because there's a cultural issue at play
with all of this you mentioning this kid
who got burned I gotta tell you man
where I grew up if anybody bullied the
burn kid that bully would get stomped
out in the playground yeah like dude
everybody was kind of like bro you
crossed the line and that's a cultural
phenomenon of kids who had some kind of
moral code or just like Scruples sounds
like where you came from it was
different yeah and there no one like
this bully knew he could do it nobody
would stop him yeah it was a bigger kid
who got left back a bunch of times and
everyone was afraid of him so this and
he would beat the crap out of anybody
and anyone he wanted yeah this is kind
of messed up so when I was uh when I was
14 years old my mother passed away from
cancer and you know it was traumatizing
event I watched the whole thing happen
in real time in front of my face you
know just a horrible horrible event took
an entire year of suffering and my best
friend you know knew that I was
depressed like it was about six months
or so after she passed away and you know
nothing would make me laugh nothing
could crack like I was just in a funk
and then one day we were talking about
something and he just turns me and he
goes yeah well at least my mom isn't
dead
and I just went
oh and I just started laughing so hard
it broke me out of my phone and I just
started laughing again I don't know what
it was but I do think and I'm not trying
to be like you know soft here but I do
think we are coming at this from a very
masculine world view like like because
like we are told to top be tough be hard
you know and a lot of this a lot of the
you know a lot of this leftist stuff
comes from feminism and feminists of
women who wanted to be soft and wanting
to take care of people's feelings and
wanting to protect people which I
totally understand right
you want to come into the heat get ready
to get burned I agree I agree but you
got to understand that like a a big
portion of what we are opposing here in
wokism is post-modern feminism right and
that that's that's feelings over facts
right so we've got to be sensitive to
that in order to have a conversation
with people who think that we're we're
insensitive and that we're not thinking
about that we're these hard cold Randy
and unfeeling Libertarians so what
you're saying is that you know men are
smart logical and tough and women are
frail weak and that's what you say
you mentioned before that I'm using
institutional power full of guys
emotionally abuse someone is over the
line and I agree with you and I think
the definition of institutional power
has changed since internet videos become
so prominent now a 13 year old that has
700 000 followers on Tick Tock is the
institutional power and for a young
unfocused child just to let their
wildness out on another human is like
heavily abusive and and dangerous and
can rally crowds of people to do it so
what do you say to them toughen up kid
you know you got 13 million followers
you know you're aiming it at them you're
telling them to go and harass them
essentially you just say Hey kid this is
the world that you live in now you know
it's these aren't problems that we use
they don't seem to work you can't like
tell someone to stop on this you got a
ban that well what they've been doing is
Banning them off the platform right and
that's like I don't know if that's the
way to go yeah when I was at VidCon this
is maybe seven or eight years ago that's
ancient I'm out in front of um it's an
Anaheim Convention Center I'm out in
front
I think on my skateboard on my skating
and I hear there's a group of little
kids like probably 12 13 and one kid
goes you have 85 subscribers how and
then he's like I just made videos and
the kid was like I have 40. like these
kids are talking to each other about how
many followers they have that freaked me
out I was like that's gonna warp those
kids Minds their whole world is going to
be attached to the number of points they
get their influence numbers like what I
want to say about like you know Ben
Shapiro he's his famous statement you
know facts don't care about your
feelings he's right about that but
that's from our world view the outside
world feelings don't care about our
facts well I've long said that and a lot
of a lot of other people have said the
same thing too and that's the more
important thing to understand Ben
Shapiro is factually correct facts don't
care about feelings but you need to
understand in the political the
political reality is that their feelings
don't care about your facts so how do we
learn this language right how do we this
is like learning a brand new language we
have to be able to learn this language
in order to be able to counteract it I
think no no no look look you're correct
but we know the language I I used to do
non-profit fundraising it's evil I think
I think these industry I think the
industry is evil I think I realize that
life's organizations were just lying and
that what they teach people is
specifically the language of feelings
they give you scripts they break down
how the scripts work so they teach you
exactly how to speak their language and
you know what there are hype there are
high functioning individuals who can
build a podcast or a media platform
knowing that language
that means they're probably manipulating
their followers or you can be the quote
unquote right and have real
conversations often disagree and say
it's cool that we disagree but not try
to use emotional manipulation really
what it comes down to is on a show like
this if we tried to engage in Hearts
office tree we'd get annihilated by by
the audience they would say you guys are
liars and it's obvious because I think
what's really starting to split the Two
Worlds is facts versus feelings and the
people who are all about facts aren't
going to be swayed by emotional
manipulation that's most of the people
who are watching this show and the
inverse and then it's the inverse you
watch a show like uh like h3h3 or or
Hassan and it's going to be all
emotional manipulation with very little
facts hence the Democrats right now will
say we gotta get off fossil fuels and
shut down the Keystone Pipeline hey
Saudi Arabia keep pumping that gas how
can both of those things be true but do
we want this balkanization I guess is
the question I mean if you're an
anarchist then yeah you want to you know
break everybody up into separate
Independence republics of individuals
right but if you want to live in the
United States like do you want Hassan to
come on this show and talk to you
because right now we are we exactly
but that's is that what we want no we
want I want you know Hassan to come in
here and engage with us I want to talk
to these people I want to have these
conversations when I reach out to
leftists and liberals to try and get
them on the show they won't do it listen
Ethan Klein got suspended on YouTube
because he said that um if there is
another
he said there's another Holocaust he
hopes that uh Ben goes first which is
shocking and defensive now my position
Ben's position and most people in our
space was basically like he shouldn't be
banned for that he's just kind of a dick
Ethan Klein himself tweeted before that
cancel culture is often a good thing and
when he's been canceled in the past it
helps him reflect and become a better
person when he got his sponsors pulled
because he made gay stereotype jokes he
said well I guess I'm a threat to gay
people so you know whatever and he was
kind of bummed about it when he makes
offensive comments about Ben Shapiro he
claimed white supremacists got him
banned well I'm sorry I got to pause
there a second you mean you made a joke
about guessing Ben and you thought white
supremacists were mad about it they I'm
sorry they agree with you Ethan but it's
it but my point is
it's it's nonsensical there's no logic
there there's no fact to follow he's
saying two things that contradict each
other however in the world of emotion
that doesn't matter so of course it's
true we are in this world where we look
for logical consistency and we often
don't understand how they could be
trapped in that world because they don't
need logical consistency they need
emotional consistency and what's that
hating us well what no I think uh Ethan
was J was joking and jiving Ben like it
was an emotional an attempt to
emotionally bond with Ben Shapiro are
you kidding dude I know how people like
that you're saying you're saying that
Ethan Klein saying he hopes Ben Shapiro
gets gassed was to bond with that he's
like listen fellow Jew take take
responsibility for your jewishness let's
be together on this one like kind of
thing it was an emotional way to to say
that and it came out as a dirty joke
emotional in the sense that it would
make the average person want to fight
you I guess yeah kind of like with a
friend and you're like no make an
insulting joke to your friend they're
like oh yeah and then you get like a
bonding no way dude so you are that is a
a one times one
hold on look when you are a personality
that consistently attacks insults
derides and makes it makes money off of
harming like like attacking other people
and then one day you go on your show and
outright say you hope if it comes down
to it they die I'm sorry bro and you're
not attacking other people you mean
insulting other people I don't like
attack used in conversational terms it's
not you're not attacking each other like
these are these are people who
celebrated cancel culture celebrated the
the harm to people's livelihoods and
then complain when it happens to them
they advocate for a world of pain and
then demand it does not befall them when
look if if I said this the other day if
I came out and said similar comments
about AOC ain't nobody's gonna call that
a joke we're critical of AOC we're not
friends with her he is not friends with
Ben Shapiro no what he said about him
was not bonding it was a dog it was an
attempt to bond oh come through emotion
it was an attempt emotional attempt to
bond it was an attempt to ride an insult
for the sake of making money why would
he bond with somebody that he argues
with and doesn't like politically and
and is is complete different
uh natural human tendency can I take an
informal poll amongst you guys on the
subject of national divorce yay or nay
nay no no yay okay so I'm a nay uh as
well so we got one yay what about you
search
um I think the US is strong because it's
many different agents maybe if it was a
divorce where it was kind of like larger
regions the United States maybe okay so
it's like a larger balkanization okay
but I don't I don't necessarily know I
wouldn't be able to say that so then yay
so then that means that we've got to
figure out a way to live with these
people right and Bill Maher's been
talking about this on his show a couple
of times no we don't have to figure out
a way to believe these people no we
don't that's why we have States and
that's why people have championed
federalism well because California
states have Democrats in them that's
that's that's fine and the internet
California can do its California's thing
so long as we outline where they're
infringe upon our rights for instance
California allowing tons of illegal
immigrants to come in then using that in
the census to gain a congressional seat
or an electoral vote is a violation of
our rights that needs to be adjudicated
but if California wants to have illegal
immigrants that don't count towards
their senses I could care less how can
we live in a country with with people
who think that we are semi-fascists
right how can we live how can we call
those people in our country listen
Luke and say National divorce right
listen we tolerate that there are
countries in this world that want us all
dead we need to find a way to not fight
with each other war is bad yes yes so
the same goes for even within this
country I think California is a very
awful place there's poop in the streets
they they ignore federal laws the only
thing I'm concerned about is there are
benefits to being part of the Union that
make us strong and protect us from say
Chinese communism Chinese Communist
party but I don't like the fact that
when they become a sanctuary State and
defy federal law it gives them Federal
power that should be adjudicated I think
if it came down to it a peaceful divorce
is better than a civil war but I would
prefer this country remain together in
fact I prefer the United States actually
expand buying Greenland let's agree
let's get it we need to add more States
uh
[Laughter]
I don't want Canada
I don't know where the oil is
it that doesn't matter I like Montreal
you don't have to deal with all of
Canada
if you guys just listen to me and do
what I want Let's see we can avoid a
whole bunch of property ones I I think
it's important to prioritize you know
when I talk about National divorce when
I'm specifically talking about is
prioritizing states rights limiting the
federal government allowing people to
individually decide their own kind of
Destiny but at the same time you could
also have defense packs you could also
say hey we're going to protect each
other hey we're going to have a strong
National Defense if one of us gets
attacked we're going to have an alliance
but the federal government that dictates
how we should be living our life that's
just too much there we don't need all
these departments we don't need all
these Regulators we don't need all these
rules we don't need all these taxes we
could go states by state into federalism
Alexander Hamilton federalism but at the
same time that would mean a peaceful
divorce because we're not reliant on the
federal government we're giving us
together no no no a very weak federal
government for the purpose of of shared
National Defense
roads and things like that for the most
part we're talking about federalism you
keep the roads I don't want the roads
let the roads be private that's not how
the whole Road conversation
but Luke the first thing that's going to
happen is Missouri's going to war with
Kansas I don't think so I I think
they'll why why would you why well you
guys must not be from Missouri first of
all Jayhawks border War we've had a
problem with them since the late 1800s
but uh that was what Alexander Hamilton
argued in the Federalist was that if we
do not have a central federal government
that puts us all in a fifth you know
whatever the arrangement was 13 colonies
13 states at the time that they they
would be more willing to go to war with
one another and that the tensions
between the states will be alleviated
because they could seek redress
throughout the federal government and I
think that that argument has been proven
true I I and I think that's actually
fantastic and it's it's partly how I
describe uh International efforts or uh
I don't want to say globalism because
that that is a connotation towards
because of One World Government if we
were all under like Star Trek kind of a
situation but I'm saying this imagine
the United States had Sovereign rights
over its borders and trade but instead
of War we adjudicated things through a
court it's preferable all to War I don't
want to see our troops overseas blowing
up anybody or getting blown up I don't
want to see nukes fired as much as it
might suck it's better so in that sense
there is a path towards
can I one more one thing real quick Luke
I want to blow your mind here with a
little like situation here in the
globalist thing right would you rather
live on an earth that was a one world
government that was governed under the
United States Constitution or would you
rather live in a world where it had
hundreds of of governments but they were
all like North Korea one one world
government with a constitution right so
I mean you're a globalist no I I I've
never I've I've often talked about this
globalism it's inevitable I've often
said how are we going to do so one world
government is inevitable in your mind
yeah it is
true I was just gonna say that's the
argument I was going to make because
because what you were just saying
essentially if you're saying oh we're
all going to be together so we don't
fight each other why don't we just
create a world government just like you
know the Rockefellers has called for and
sexualized
but this will be improved but this is
something but this is the court of my
argument right there's centralization of
power there's a monopoly power and then
there's decentralization I think we
should always be striving and pushing
and advocating for the decentralization
of power not for the centralization
because when you centralize it enough
you have a world government and that's
essentially the wet dream of many
Eugenics
you're conflating a bunch of issues that
don't need to be conflated right your
point about a one world governor of the
American Constitution is a good one if
it was actually the American
Constitution that's a really really good
thing the issue here is you are correct
about decentralization of power Luke but
simply because we would have a very weak
treaty between countries for
adjudication of Border disputes and
resource disputes does not mean
eugenicists will start massacring
children of course not just like you
were talking about annexing Canada right
so if we added a 51st state what you're
talking about is moving towards
essentially that one world government
what if Russia was just a state what if
Mexico was just a state right and then
everyone was governor see that's why
like you have to be careful when you say
oh well decentralization is good because
ultimately you could say well you know
North Korea is very decentralized but
it's not governed very well right so the
question really is is are individual
rights protected that's what I think is
really important and so the question is
is when we talk about big government is
it the size of government that matters
or is it if that government protects
individual rights and these are
questions to ask myself I don't know the
answer to that because but the American
government is bigger than North Korea
but I would rather live in the American
government that is bigger but everyone
works for the government in North Korea
but this is the thing and there's a
correlation between big governments and
Liberty going down so when you look at
that correlation historically this is
why you always the North Korean
government is bigger than our government
the North Korean government is absolute
in their country from border to border
every everyone works for the government
is is controlled by the government and
enslaved by the government but there are
plenty of objective measures that the
United States government is much larger
than that you're making budgetary yes
but hold on you're making an argument
employee okay okay I get it you're
making an argument about hard number to
number number if I'm talking about crime
in Omaha Nebraska and New York what
matters the hard numbers of murders or
the per capita murders per capita per
capita if we're talking about the size
of government North Korea is as big as
government can be it's because they're a
small country physically does not mean
they're a smaller government than ours
100 percent government everybody's in
the government so it's I agree
everyone's applying for the government
there's what percentage of the
population is involved with working for
the government yeah with the United
States I mean look at New York New York
has between 30 and 40 000 cops out of uh
2.5 million just in Manhattan alone that
is very little government enforcement
relative to the size of the population I
disagree you're wrong and uh I'll tell
you why because if the government of the
United States wanted to accomplish what
North Korea is doing it could in many
ways it does the size of the government
can be met you what you said is a
subjective measurement we I could take
my own measurements and say yeah
the the laws of North Korea that exists
Define what you mean by government size
okay I'm talking about the budget the
national budget I'm talking about the
number of bureaucracies that exist the
number of bureaucrats that work in those
bureaucracies a number of offices
appointed offices right the size and
scope of the U.S federal government by
any objective measure other than what
that government can do to its citizens
and the power that it has over its
citizens by that measurement I would
give that to you North Korea is a larger
government in that it can reach into its
citizens lives and accomplish more in
controlling its citizens lives in the
U.S federal government which I think is
what matters right it that is what
matters so the problem there can be an
argument made that the United States I
would disagree with your assessment is
that population size doesn't dictate
size of government in any meaningful way
just because there's 330 million people
here by necessity you have people who
work in government a certain percentage
but that percentage is minuscule
Compared to North Korea right but it's
my point that it doesn't matter
necessarily what the size of government
is stands because you would still rather
live in a government that is governed
under the United States in a world that
is governed under the U.S Constitution
then it then there's one that is
decentralized republics but they're all
governed by like North Korea but I would
even encounter saying no one even
respects the Constitution anymore do you
think New York State respects the Second
Amendment they don't they absolutely
don't and and this idea to change their
laws to adjust to what the Supreme Court
has done suggests that you're incorrect
yeah I I yeah yeah but at the same time
look look what the reality is in New
York state look what the reality that a
lot of people are living under when
their basic rights are being violated by
the NSA by the federal government spying
on everything you would get rid of the
U.S Constitution uh absolutely not uh
but but I would say government is
imperfect but one of the the most
closest you know better ideas is of
course the Constitution but now we have
to face the reality
foreignly a lot of federal bureaucrats
because there's so much government they
don't respect to the Constitution the
idea of the Constitution is something
that they don't even know and understand
because of how big our bureaucracy is
and I would even argue that just two
years ago we lived under a North Korean
type government that went around locked
down businesses and shut people's
livelihoods down and made them not even
be able to uh you know walk around
freely in many ends depending on your
state didn't happen to us in Missouri
exactly why because decentralization
because states are able to decide what's
right for themselves but if you lived in
Australia right the court cases that
came out used the U.S Constitution as
precedent so it was the Federal
Government ultimately and the 14th
amendment that many of these court cases
relied on so without if we had gone into
you know National divorce Luke how could
we have how could you have used the
Constitution as president you say they
ignored it but I mean the court cases
suggest otherwise and and when Alex
Jones Goes to the Supreme Court right it
will be the federal laws that he will
use to protect him and his Free Speech
but a lot of times that is interpreted
up to the judges to make decisions that
are not always is beholden to the
Constitution the Constitution is not a
perfect idea but it's one of the best
perfect ideas that we have come close to
and I agree with you we should try to
protect the Constitution but at the same
time we live in a reality where it's
just been thrown to the side and we
can't deny that thanks for checking out
this segment from the Tim cast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there